[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en la
amazonía y en las nuevas promesas hechas
para poder salvar el pulmón del mundo
hechas por Lula y por Petro nos
acompañan en este estudio tres invitados
que ya les presento Stefan rosten es
arqueólogo y director de investigaciones
en el centro nacional de investigación
científica laboratorio de arqueología de
las Américas bienvenido Gracias Joel da
Costa referente de Cáritas Francia en la
amazonía que se encarga de velar por los
derechos humanos en todos los países de
la región amazónica bienvenido Joel
Gracias Carlos y Sebastián belú es
geógrafo profesor en el instituto de
altos estudios de América Latina
bienvenido Gracias radiografía de los
retos de la amazonía hoy nuestro asunto
en Primera Plana
con selvas y ríos inmensos que albergan
naturaleza única que sustenta una
diversidad cultural notable en 7
millones de kilómetros cuadrados la
amazonía es de Gran importancia para
Sudamérica y para todo el planeta esta
gran porción de la biosfera compartida
por nueve países alberga casi el 10% de
la biodiversidad de la tierra pero la
amazonía es también vulnerable a los
impactos del actual sistema de
desarrollo se estima que un 17% de los
bosques amazónicos han sido
transformados para darles otro uso las
actividades económicas que amenazan la
región incluyen la ganadería agricultura
extensivas y actividades extractivas
elegales en este contexto los anuncios
del recién posesionado presidente de
Brasil Lula da Silva sobre una Cumbre
por la amazonía para tomar medidas
efectivas para su protección y del
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro de
un gran acuerdo amazónico para darle un
nuevo enfoque regional serán
fundamentales en el futuro próximo repas
algunas portadas diario El espectador
reclama con esta portada Más compromiso
ante la deforestación amazónica con esta
llamativa portada de un amazonas tintado
de rojo la revista brasileña bella
denuncia a los crímenes en la región
amazónica nombrando el caso del
periodista británico y el indigenista
brasileño Don Philips y Bruno Pereira si
lo recuerdan el año pasado Pereira
combatía la pesca legal en tierras
protegidas Los Ángeles Times Lula
promete un nuevo día para la amazonía
brasileña luego hablaremos de esos
compromisos la amazonía lleva podemos
decir Stefan años en crisis luego
hablaremos de responsabilidades y de
promesas pero antes de nada Cuál es su
estado actual si tuviéramos que hacer
una radiografía de varias pinceladas
para explicar a nuestros espectadores y
oyentes para hacernos una idea de su
estado en 2023 creo que podemos dar tres
palabras que la primera es el tamaño no
hay que olvidar son 7 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados El tamaño de
Australia y habla de la amazonía me
parece hay que abandonar esa idea de
hablar de las amazonías plural Es como
hablar de cósica de Francia y de
Inglaterra son países diferentes la
segunda es la biodiversidad la mega
biodiversidad que es una fuerza pero
también una debilidad porque con esa
mega diversidad biodiversidad es un
mundo frágil que se está perdiendo y
vamos a pasar en poco tiempo en la al
lado oscuro de
nuestro impacto sobre la nacionalidad y
para trabajes me parece importante de
hablar también de la etno diversidad
hay muchos grupos indígenas se hablan
todavía casi 300 idiomas indígenas pero
también hay los colonos y es
asunto digamos un poquito difícil porque
es un lugar Tropical que no conocemos
tanto y nunca escuchamos a los
habitantes que tienen que
eso creo que es el cambio para entender
mejor la amazonía precisamente de los
habitantes de los pueblos autóctonos
sobre todo digamos el negociado de Joel
no sí lo que acaba de decir Stephanie
creo que es importante Mostrar que en
amazonía es una amazonía diversa a donde
hay más de 500 pueblos indígenas que
están viviendo allá en nueve países y
hay una diversidad muy grande entre
manaos capital
gigantesca 2 millones de personas y el
pueblo venezolano por ejemplo en el
caqueta colombiano hay realmente cosas
diferentes pero también hay puntos
comunes y creo que un de los puntos
comunes en relación a los pueblos
indígenas es desafortunadamente
todo el trabajo que hacen y que reci
amenazas amenazas que pueden ser contra
sus vidas pero también del trabajo que
hacen todos los días para mejorar sus
situaciones para oír sus voces
diferentes distintas y vemos
desafortunadamente que en los últimos en
las últimas décadas hubo más de 300
muertas de líderes que sean indígenas
pero también afro también
campesinos Y creo que eso es lo más
importante que tenemos que hablar hoy es
eso dar la palabra las voces de los
territorios amazónicos luego hablaremos
de esas amenazas claro de 300 Por
ejemplo lo que diferenciará son los
casos que mediáticamente trascienden
pero cuántos hay que usted conoce bien y
que no y que luego los medios no
Tratamos de ello Sebastián dónde ponemos
para la radiografía del estado actual en
Con qué se queda yo creo que hay que
subrayar el hecho desde que todos mundo
conoce que desde cuatro años Brasil no
ha tomado la precauciones de vida al
contrario ha sido gobierno incentivando
la ocupación y explotación de la
brasileña y lo que vemos en otros países
que conforman la gigantesca Cuenca
amazónica es son esta tendencia a
explotar cada vez más la selva los
recursos minerales las aguas la fauna
todo eso representan amenaza para la
región y para sus pueblos también según
el panel científico por la amazonía en
los últimos 36 años la región ha perdido
atención un 17% de su vegetación nativa
a causa de la deforestación no sé
Estefan si estamos ya ante un punto de
no retorno un punto Irreversible ahí
algunos expertos que calculan que el
punto de ruptura está entre el 20 y el
25%, no esto es no retorno ya que la
respuesta optimista o la respuesta real
Pues la verdad es que no lo sé me hace
una muy buena pregunta quizá la real
ya estamos en este punto porque se habla
mucho del del de Brasil pero los otros
países también están en una
deforestación tremenda que sea Perú que
sea Ecuador que sea Colombia y no
sabemos tanto sobre Venezuela pero es
igual
hay que saber también que son 50 años de
de utilizar los recursos de la selva
pero en realidad son doscientos años que
estamos sacando árboles animales
oro y bastante recursos hemos empezado
hace más de 200 años sin ver que hay
13.000
13.000 años de ocupación indígena y con
una resilencia de la selva que nunca
hemos observado o aplicado y estamos
jugando como como niños manejeados hasta
acá las consecuencias y creo que al
nivel internacional pero también a nivel
de los estados de la amazonía hay que
darse cuenta que la amazonía es un gran
peligro está enferma básicamente
deforestación minería agricultura
actividades ilegales son varias las
amenazas pero si pudiéramos ponderarlas
un poco Establecer un poco la jerarquía
de esas amenazas realmente es imposible
por qué porque todas estas actividades
estás están conectadas hay deforestación
porque para hacer business
agroforestería hay actividades minerías
que hacen Pues ahí hay desplazamientos
de los pueblos indígenas y de los otros
pueblos así que no se puede realmente
poner no se puede decir por ejemplo si
mañana acabamos con las Industrias agro
vamos a mejorar no es tan fácil porque
al lado va a haber otras actividades
creo que es un conjunto y y para un poco
también seguir lo que Estefan dijo el
punto de estamos casi Ahí casi creo que
hay todavía Esperanza porque si no si si
seguimos con eso pues podemos seguir
mañana va a ser 25 o 30 es lo que
tenemos que hacer es parar realmente
completamente con el sistema actual que
está en el territorio amazónico un
sistema que hace deforestación un
sistema que hace explotación mineras que
hay también un sistema que no permite a
los pueblos indígenas de realmente
proponer alternativas porque Stephen
dijo hace más de 13.000 años que los
pueblos indígenas viven allá que tiene
su cosmovisión que tiene el buen vivir
que es una un tema bastante interesante
que se está democratizando que muestra
la armonía entre los pueblos y la
naturaleza creo que lo importante es
Mostrar que estas alternativas existen y
que todavía no es tarde se puede
Sebastián
de acuerdo con lo que acaba de plantear
O sea que toda esta amenaza funcionan de
manera sistémica la una empuja a la otra
y entonces no hay una más peligrosa que
otra pero quisiera agregar un punto
sobre este Eso de no retorno O sea la
capacidad de resiliencia que tienen o no
los medios y además de la deforestación
estamos también viendo efectos del
cambio climático en la amazonía y la
amazonía producía su propio ambiente
donde la digamos las células se podía
regenerar y eso ya no es posible en
algunas regiones que se están
transformando en sabana o sea de la
labor esta no podría volver si no quizás
en muchísimos años
y luego hay una cuestión bastante dentro
de las amenazas que el drama de la
deforestación en la amazonía tiene
aristas complejas entre Lo legal y lo
ilegal la agricultura y la ganadería son
industrias legales y bastante fuertes en
los países sudamericanos cuyas economías
dependen en un importante medida de
ellas y son promovidas por gobiernos de
países amazónicos como Brasil almiste
internacional describe el modelo ya
establecido para apropiarse de un
terreno iniciar incendios de manera
ilegal despejar con ellos enormes áreas
de coberturas selvática y abrir
para los animales claro es un entramado
con una cara legal y con una con otra
cara ilegal y con participación de los
gobiernos
Esa es la cosa que decía es una es un
complejo el puzzle los países mismos
amazónicos tienen que tomar en
conciencia lo que pasa
he vivido bastante allá y los países
andinos amazónicos que sea Bolivia Perú
Ecuador Colombia Venezuela Ven a su a
los Andes
utilizando realmente
con la amazonía como fuente de recursos
y no tienen una una visión digamos
ecológica de lo que pasa de lo que
tienen que hacer y más bien siguen
abriendo la selva hay un sistema por
ejemplo en Ecuador pero también Brasil
se abre una carretera para
desenclavarlo la gente indígenas Y esa
carretera se se hace en una
colonización abierta de después de pocos
pocos años ya la amazonía de este camino
está abierta por colonos y por
campesinos y es totalmente legal pero es
la manera de comer es la amazonía que se
hace en muchos lugares especialmente
empaques si se abre una carretera hasta
un parque indígena
se abre la puerta a bastante abusos
ecológicos que además han sido cometidos
por gobiernos tanto de derechas Como de
izquierdas aquí nos ha salvado nadie lo
que lo que a lo mejor cambia a partir de
ahora es la conciencia ecológica desde
hace poco no sí sí creo que es
importante decir es que porque acabamos
de ver que en Brasil y en Colombia hay
dos presidentes que se dice
Defensores de la amazonía obviamente
vamos a ver eso está por ahora en el
papel y sobre todo de Lula ya fue
presidente durante dos mandatos y
desafortunadamente no ha cambiado
completamente el sistema Durante los dos
mandatos de Lula hubo deforestación no
tan grave como solar Obviamente que no
pero el sistema no ha cambiado es por
eso que veo también algunas diferencias
entre Lula de los dos primeros y luna de
hoy Bueno en la conciencia que todos
somos asumido respeto con ecológicamente
también está ahí no suponemos
vamos a hacer una breve pausa en este
punto y enseguida seguimos analizando la
amazonía aquí en Primera Plana hasta
ahora
[Música]
sabe cómo identificarlas acompáñenos 24
vea como distinguir entre información y
contenido falso en las redes sociales
desinformando una herramienta para
verificar y contextualizar información
es información certificada todos los
días en todas nuestras emisiones
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando los retos que tiene por
delante la amazonía el pulmón del mundo
lo hacemos con el arqueólogo Stefan
rostán el referente de Cáritas Francia
Joel da Costa y el geógrafo Sebastián
belu Lula necesita al mundo para salvar
la amazonía tituló a Hace unos días una
Tribuna del New York Times y le pregunto
Sebastián estamos ante el mayor reto del
estrenado mandato de Lula se trata de un
reto regional incluso internacional no
sé si hay conciencia de ello primero
quisiera recordar que hace casi 20 años
15 el presidente de Ecuador Rafael
Correa intentó también crear un fondo
para no explotarlos hidrocarburos de la
zona de yasuni y proteger la selva
finalmente eso no funciona o sea no
consiguió los fondos se terminó
autorizando la explotación petrolera en
este territorio entonces no es una idea
muy nueva pensar o apelar al mundo para
que ayuden con la protección de la
amazonía con fondos y por otra parte ese
no es el único reto que tiene Lula Lula
tiene primero un reto político de cómo
va a gobernar Brasil y vimos el 8 de
enero que eso no iba a ser fácil
entonces son dos dimensiones muy
complejas la novedad ahora creo que como
tú bien lo mencionaste hay más
conciencia de la necesidad de una
protección más respectivas pero
programas internacionales para la
amazonía hubo muchos entonces hay que
ver cómo simplemente Cuáles son los
instrumentos
si puede ser efectivamente
eficientes Lula también planea
fortalecer los órganos federales
encargados de proteger la selva mientras
sus ministros han anunciado la creación
de una unidad Federal policial para
investigar a la sofisticadas bandas
criminales responsables de la
depredación de los recursos naturales
cómo funcionan las actividades ilegales
en la amazonía Cómo funcionan estas
estas bandas ilegales
creo que no hay frontera entre Lo legal
y lo ilegal es la primera idea que que
sí que está ahí no Cuándo es el legal
cuando no es en guayana francesa hay
muchos ilegales que vienen y se mezclan
con gente que trabaja de manera legal y
igual en Perú o en Venezuela o en
Colombia la gente tiene actividades
legal y desbordan muchas veces o mandan
por ejemplo en Perú mandan a gente para
matar a los Indígenas si no hay
indígenas bueno en la deforestación de
zonas que empieza siendo ilegal luego se
pone una etiquetita un código de barras
ese árbol y pasa la legalidad no es
decir es por eso Esas fronteras tan
borrosas entre la legalidad y la
ilegalidad Sí ese pero son Claro que
cada país decide de lo que hace pero es
esa idea de abrir al mundo es necesario
necesaria al mismo tiempo hemos visto
casi años que
la cuestión de la amazonía se abre al
mundo y no hay tantos efectos y me hace
pensar Estuve en una copa sin pozo para
hablar del cambio climático en los
trópicos y había solamente europeos
blancos que hablaban de eso no había ni
un solo indígena para hablar de lo que
saben mejor
de esa gestión y eso Tal vez Lula tendrá
puede pedir a los habitantes mismos de
la amazonas que soluciones hay Porque
esa gente sabe muchas veces las
soluciones simples y locales que hay que
que que
tomarlos por los autóctonos
este comentario porque es exactamente
eso lo vemos desde muchos años hay mucho
más organización que se están
estructurando Hay una confederación que
se llama la coica que Federación de las
organizaciones indígenas de la Cuenca
amazónica que es un poco la
confederación de todas las
organizaciones indígenas de amazonía que
piden desde muchos años que tiene que
escuchar la voz que tienen que oír
realmente lo que los territorios si
quieren organizan foro yo acabo de
regresar de Belén en donde hubo el foro
social Panamá sónico y ahí sí no había
únicamente europeos blancos había
algunos Bueno yo por ejemplo pero la
mayoría de la gente que Samaná venía de
los diferentes pueblos indígenas y
estaban promoviendo también alternativa
porque ellos creen realmente que el
punto de no retorno todavía no está ahí
Y creo que es lo más importante es que
Lula Petro y también los otros gobiernos
tienen que oír realmente Esas voces
Sebastián Yo creo que cuando hablamos
también de actividades ilegales como
bien mencionó estefano o sea las
fronteras son muy borrosas pero una de
las causas es la pobreza hay que hay que
entender que la gente va a la amazonía
porque tiene la esperanza que va a poder
ganar mucha plata o algo de plata con
Estas actividades por ejemplo la
explotación del oro y la otra dimensión
obviamente la falta absoluta de control
del estado en estos territorios y la
gran corrupción que existe pero o sea
hay causas estructurales Y eso lleva
también a que los pobres que vienen de
las ciudades para explotar los placeres
se encuentren matando eliminando
transmitiendo enfermedades a los indios
hay una lucha aquí entre pueblos
marginados ambos en la sociedad
brasileña peruana ecuatoriana
Estefan en su caso y por sus trabajos
conoce bien la amazonía ecuatoriana allí
parece que en el gran problema de la
expansión de la minería ilegal las
operaciones policiales en 2022 han
descubierto niveles impactantes de
deterioro ambiental causado por esta
práctica en la provincia de Napo en esta
zona del Amazonas ecuatoriano un poco
desarrollada y de difícil navegación la
minería de oro se ha expandido en un
catastrófico 21.000 por ciento en las
últimas dos décadas Cómo se ha producido
esta expansión es que es muy difícil de
controlar también la amazonía en
cualquier país está al frente de ese
problema que es tan grande que no pueden
controlar todo y también a veces no
quieren controlar las cosas y pero la
extracción también es la legal hay
compañías extranjeras que vienen en el
caso de Ecuador a explotarla
espacios se quedan Algunos años la
pobreza es un asunto fuerte porque
ayudan mucho a la gente y viven como una
edad de oro que se rompe cuando se van y
dejan todo abierto todo destruido y yo
he visto
espacios
así de alegría de plata y que
desaparecen Después de cinco diez años
vuelve a un estado destruido y hasta las
mentiras de las compañías por ejemplo
una compañía norteamericana que votaba
los desechos de
petróleo en sobre las carreteras
que era un líquido negro feo y decía a
la gente a los autóctonos eso es muy
bueno para la piel la gente se ponía
sobre la piel esa Claro que hubo cáncer
por todos lados unos 20 años después hay
las mentiras de las compañías creo que
siempre se habla de lo legado lo ilegal
Más bien es La La La La La La La La La
La propensión está activista que tenemos
eh que sean compañías internacionales o
nacionales que disponen realmente la
amazonía
a partir de esta radiografía Nos
gustaría además extender la reflexión a
otras cuestiones no que tienen que ver
con la amazonía creen que hay muchas
ideas falsas que nos hemos fabricado
aquí en Europa sobre la amazonía
Sebastián antes le pregunta a Sebastián
ante fuera de Antonio y me ha dicho
todas
todas vivimos con muchas imágenes de la
amazonía muchas sí Muchos mitos también
y primero hay que decir que hay
conocimiento de la amazonía como el
conocimiento científico pero no tanto o
sea falta estudiar mucho más y también
porque seguimos transmitiendo esta
imagen del pulmón del planeta la no es
un pulmón un pulmón digamos que absorbe
oxígeno y la amazonía absorbe CO2
entonces no es un pulmón para empezar
entonces Empezamos mal y también este
mito de una riqueza digamos inagotable
que hace que la gente vaya a la amazonía
y no es así o sea las riquezas la que
hay son agradables y hay que manejarla
con mucho cuidado pero sobre estos temas
hay un excelente libro de Stefany que
recomiendo leer Sí bueno el título Cuál
es el título del libro los dos los doce
trabajos de de las huellaciones
amazónicas creo
también sacar el cliché de una sola
amazonas
dos millones de habitantes es ciudad es
una ciudad que podría ser estar acá en
Europa o en otro país pero al mismo
tiempo también hay territorios a donde
hay pueblos no contactados por ejemplo
eso sigue siendo realidad pero tampoco
es la realidad de toda la amazonía
porque mucho mucha gente cree aquí en
Europa que la gente que vive en amazonas
en amazonía son indígenas por ejemplo no
son únicamente indígenas hay una
diversidad de población muy grande y el
otro cliché es decir ya es tarde lo que
para retomar un poco el tema por no
estar el derrotismo sí no juega a favor
de corriente Exactamente
eso bueno no cambiamos nada no cambiamos
nada dejamos entonces amazonía
deforestando quemándose y todo eso no
Bueno pues les hago la contra pregunta y
aquí nos tenemos que agarrar para
entender que esa respuesta puede tener
Esperanza puede tener optimismo antes
este me decía bueno quiere que le
responda de la forma real lo de la forma
optimista creo que me ha puesto muchos
datos sobre la mesa para responderme de
la forma real le pido ahora que me
responda de la forma optimista A dónde
nos podemos agarrar a que a la gente los
habitantes Mira tenemos 300 años de
ciencia occidental en la amazonía y
pensamos saber todo pero cada día
encontramos nuevo hemos encontrado un
río en el cielo en Brasil que está sobre
el Amazonas hemos encontrado un río
adentro del suelo a Kilómetros adentro
bajo el Amazonas estamos aprendiendo
poco a poco la amazonía los indígenas lo
he dicho tienen 13.000 años y en 13.000
años de observaciones de ciencia porque
tienen un mensaje es diferente que no es
la nuestra han visto cosas y tenemos que
aprender de ellos para para conocer más
Esa esa amazonía pero también para
encontrar soluciones que siempre digo
Son locales más que internacionales
para para ver cuáles son las Cuáles son
las soluciones para salvar esta amazonía
eso es la respuesta final
para contrastar un poquito con lo que
está diciendo Estefany que comparto o
sea esta es la visión local y Hay
también una visión más regional o sea
todos los países de la región y yo creo
que aquí hay un juego también político
de la digamos acercamiento de los
gobiernos llamados de izquierda se de
reincentivar o renovar la integración
latinoamericana pero la que se ha hecho
este momento con constituye construir
rutas en la amazonia entonces hay
también que encontrar otros modelos de
digamos de en el territorio
También nosotros acá en Francia en
Europa en otros países también somos
actores de cambio tenemos que
concientizarnos sobre lo que estamos
consumiendo lo que estamos produciendo
También muchas cosas que estamos
consumiendo viene de amazonía Y eso
tenemos que pensarlo bien Exacto Pues
nos quedamos con este último punto muy
interesante Muchísimas gracias a los
tres hemos aprendido mucho hoy en este
en Primera Plana sobre la amazonía y a
todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
Muchas gracias
[Música]